وينضم الينا من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري
على خبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا وسهلا
بك
هل من مؤشرات عن قرب تنفيذ العمليه البريه
التي تتواعد بها تركيا
التصريحات السياسيه واضحه والرئيس التركي
تحدث اكثر من مره منذ عده ايام لكن الامر
تم تحويله الى خليه التخطيط الاستراتيجي
لمراعاه الارتدادات والانعكاسات على تنفيذ
هكذا عمليه وبالتالي وضع القطور العامه
لهذه العمليه اذا ما قيض لها ان تتم ولكن
هناك مستجدات على الساحه الموقف الامريكي
رغم التحفظ
الموقف الامريكي بدا
ياخذ منحه جديد يطالب قوات قصد بان تتفاوض
مع تركيا وتقدم تنازلات واهم هذه
التنازلات حسب المطالب الامريكيه اذا ما
تحققت لن تحدث عمليه بريه وتتمثل بما
بالاتي
الانسحاب قوات اسد لمسافه 30 كلم
الامر الاخر تسليم بعض قيادات حزب العمال
الكردستاني المطلوبين لتركيا
والامر الثالث ان تقوم تركيا
بانشاء نقاط مراقبه
منفرد او ضمن القوات الامريكيه والدوليه
لمراقبه هذا التنفيذ اذا امريكا الان تضغط
بهذا الاتجاه اذا تحقق هذا الشيء لن يكون
عمليه بريه لكن اذا لم بل سوريا
الديمقراطيه فنحن امام او تركيا امامها
خيارين الخيار الاول المعركه الشامله ان
تاخذ من جرابلس حتى همم
مرورا بعين بعين العرب الى تل ابيض وتاخذ
من راس العين همم الى المالكيه
وتاخذ بذلك غرب الفرات تاخذ منبج وتل رفعت
هذا الامر قد لا يكون موافقا عليه ومرفوضا
اذا هناك ستبحث عن بديل دون ذلك
عفوا من طرف من موافقه عليه
يجب ان يكون هناك موافقه امريكيه لان هذه
المنطقه بمعظمه تخضع لسيطره امريكيه
القوات الروسيه تتواجد في
مناطقت انت تصريحات اردوغان التي يقول
فيها اننا
سننفذ يتوعد بتنفيذ عمليه عابره للحدود
وانه امام تركيا لا مهم
نعم انا اتفق مع ما طرحه وبالتالي اقول هو
اما ان ينفذ عمليه شامله لانه الان تركيا
تسيطر على حوالي اكثر من 450 كيلو متر
تاخذ من همم جرابلس وحتى راس البسيط وتاخذ
من تل ابي- من تل ابيض حتى راس العين
وبقيت مسافات بينيه فاصله هذه المسافات
حوالي اكثر من 500 كيلو متر وبالتالي من
الصعوبه ان تاخذ الضوء الاخضر اذا ما هو
البديل ان ترجع الى مهاجمه النقاط الحاسمه
المزعجه
واشار لها التقيه تاخذ مطار من اغتال رفعت
منبج بعيد ومن بجمعه قدي ولا اتوقع ذلك
ولكن تذهب الى شرق الفرات تاخذ كوباني اي
تغلق المسافه من جرابلس الى تل ابيض وتذهب
الى شرق راس العين
الى عامودا والمالكيه كاهداف محدده اذا
هنا انا اتحدث عن عمليات جراحيه انتقائيه
ضد اهداف محدده مؤطره جغرافيه وليس امام
اجتياح كامل لان الاشتياح الكامل مرفوض
روسيا مرفوض امريكيا روسيا توافق في حال
واحد اذا ما خضعت تركيا للمطالب الروسيه
والمطالب الروسيه هي فيها ادلب عليها ان
تسلم الجمل الاربعين